apple's new 24-inch imac is definitely a
hit
with its brand new design the incredible
m1 chip
the beautiful 4.5 k display and the
surprisingly thin and light chassis
but now that we spent a good amount of
time with it we've actually found
five issues that we didn't expect when
apple first revealed
the new imac at their spring loaded
event in fact there's
one very important thing that apple kept
secret
until i fix it finally opened it up and
revealed what apple honestly should have
just told us
before we ordered it but before i get
into that issue
let's start with the first one which is
the display size
we already knew for many years that the
21.5 inch imac display
was super small and definitely not meant
for tech enthusiasts
or anyone trying to do productivity work
like video editing
photo editing or even simple
multitasking
so because of that many people went for
the 27 inch display
because of that crazy 5k resolution and
of course
the large display size and we're
actually currently using
two of these 27-inch imacs because the
displays are just
so sharp and large perfect for editing
our youtube videos
so naturally when apple announced the
new 24 inch imac
we thought it wouldn't be that much
smaller than the 27 inch
but now that we've got it in our office
the display is
tiny it's seriously so small compared to
the 27 inch
that it actually really bugs me and you
can definitely see the difference
in our speaker test from our last
comparison video
which you should check out if you
haven't already now part of the reason
why it's so small
might be because of apple's fine print
where they show that the display is not
actually 24 inches it's 23.5
inches so what makes it even smaller
than what all of their advertising made
it seem
like which is a bit disappointing
because that half an inch
can definitely make a difference and to
be completely honest
we were thinking of replacing my imac
pro with the new
24 inch imac since the m1 chip is so
reliable and
efficient and not that much slower for
editing the footage
that we edit on a daily basis but once i
saw the display size in real life
i decided that there's no way i'm
switching to the 24 inch
and we're gonna be waiting until later
this year for the larger
30 inch model but angelica our editor is
actually going to be testing out the 24
inch
to see how the editing experience really
is and she's going to let us know if
it's too small
or just fine for her so if you're not
already subscribed
do so right now to help us reach our
goal of 1 million subs by the end of
this year
now let's move on to the second issue
that we didn't expect to find
on the 24 inch imac and that is the
webcam
quality apple said that the webcam on
the 24-inch imac is the best in
any mac ever which basically makes it
better than the 1080p webcam on
the imac pro but in our experience
it's not always that great in the recent
imac comparison video that we made
we did a webcam and microphone test and
while the 24-inch imac looks better than
the regular 27-inch imax webcam
the imac pro actually looks the best in
that situation
with the 24 inch imac looking way over
sharpened
kind of like they cranked the hdr effect
to the max
so here's another facetime clip i took
with the 24 inch imax webcam
in a much more natural and common
lighting scenario
alright guys so here i am back on the 24
inch imac and just looking at the webcam
quality
you can kind of see noise in my jacket
and this is a black jacket
it is not gray like look how gray this
is and my face is kind of like all
flat and washed out so i don't know
what's going on
but this new 24 inch imax webcam
i don't know what's going on with the
isp but it's kind of bringing
all of the shadows up way too high and
it's just getting rid of all that
contrast
which looks subtle and natural this is
just
really flat so i don't know what apple's
doing but
yeah so as you guys just saw the webcam
is pretty good
but there's something going on with the
software tweaking that is just ruining
the image quality now on the plus side
this is something that apple can address
in a future software update
but it's just a little bit disappointing
that everyone who already bought one
has to wait and hope that the webcam is
gonna get fixed but at least
as you guys just heard in that facetime
clip the microphone quality is
absolutely incredible so i've gotta give
apple props for that now getting into
the
third issue this one really annoys me
about apple's marketing specifically the
part of their presentation
where they said that the 24 inch imac
has the best
speakers out of any mac ever on the imac
spec sheet
they show off that the speaker system
uses six speakers
which means that it should have two
tweeters for high frequency sound
two mid-range speakers for the mids and
two
force canceling subwoofers for the bass
on top of that if you look at ifixit's
recent teardown
you'll see what looks to be two very
large metal plates
built into the 24-inch imac and upon
closer inspection
you'll notice that those plates actually
kind of point to the speakers on each
side
and looking at it from another angle
it's clear that the speakers do
actually port directly into those metal
enclosures
which is a method used in the audio
world to amplify
the volume and the base of the speakers
and if you look at the previous imac
tear downs
they include those same speaker
enclosures which obviously were much
thicker than the new ones on the 24 inch
imac but anyway
the point that i'm trying to make is
that apple marketed the new speakers
to sound like they're way better than
any mac speakers ever made
but now that we've had a chance to
listen to them that's simply
not true just hear it for yourself
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
as you've just heard the volume on the
24 inch imac
is incredibly underwhelming especially
compared to
the imac pro now i will admit that the
sound quality is pretty good
especially with the vocals but the bass
is
seriously lacking on the 24 inch even
compared to the regular 27-inch imac
which isn't as good as the imac pro so
in my opinion
the speakers on the new imac are
definitely
not the best and i would 100 take the
imac pro speakers
over the new ones time and time again
and in my experience with the 24 inch
imac so far i noticed that i was trying
to turn the volume on the speakers
higher even though they were already
maxed out
which is something that always happens
with windows laptops
because their speakers are always too
quiet and that is something that should
not be happening
on an imac especially after apple said
that it packs the best speakers
on any mac but while i'm disappointed
with them i've gotta admit that they are
still
very great quality speakers that a lot
of people are gonna be very happy with
i just wish that they had a little bit
more volume now getting into the fourth
issue this is actually the one that
apple chose to keep secret
a couple of days after everyone started
receiving their 24-inch imax
luke miyani mentioned on twitter that
the base model
only has one cooling fan compared to two
on the more expensive models this makes
no sense at all because they all have
the m1 chip
and apple showed off two fans in their
24 inch imac marketing
videos they literally kept it a secret
from
everyone even after people were
receiving
their imacs but wait it gets even worse
brian tong replied to luke and mentioned
that the more expensive models
not only get two fans but they actually
get a dedicated heat pipe design
which is obviously superior in terms of
cooling performance
this literally changes everything for
someone who's struggling to choose
between the base
1300 model and the fifteen hundred
dollar model
because what if the more expensive 24
inch imac
actually ends up performing much better
thanks to the dual fan
and heat pipe cooling design well we
decided to answer that question by
going out and picking up a base model
1300
imac and we're going to be doing a very
detailed performance comparison
between that model and our current blue
model to see if there's actually any
difference
so subscribe right now so you don't miss
out on that and now let's finally finish
off with the fifth issue which isn't
that big of a deal
but i definitely was not expecting it in
apple's promotional videos of the
24-inch imac
the color seemed to be more on the
subtle side especially
on the front but now that we've got it
in our office
the blue color for some reason looks
more bold compared to what the marketing
video
showed maybe it's just the fact that
apple used renders or studio lighting
but in our office the colors look quite
a bit darker than we expected
and because of that we honestly wish
that we just
ordered the silver instead which looks
incredibly clean
and thankfully we did pick up the silver
1300 base model
so we could test out the single fan
performance and we're probably going to
be returning this blue one
and keeping the silver one because it
looks so good so i've got to say that if
you're someone who prefers more subtle
or neutral colors
you really can't go wrong with the
silver and it definitely makes it feel
more like an imac compared to the other
color options
so there you guys go those were the top
five issues with the 24 inch imac that
we did not
expect and if you disagree with any of
them go ahead and comment your thoughts
down below
but if you enjoyed this video click that
circle above to subscribe so you don't
miss out on that
bass versus high-end imac comparison
video definitely check out one of those
two right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
[Music]